hey youtubers is Charlie time to start
your game of Thrones therapy session
that's right our watch begins now like
the long watch till season 6 starts
every year it always feels like the
finales try to accomplish something a
little bit different I mean it's really
all about paying off the storylines that
they set up this season extra bonus
though is that we get to pay off some
storylines from way way back like all
the way back to Renly and Stannis so
just careful for spoilers if you haven't
seen the episode yet so we can get right
into it and new round of the giveaway
starts now I'm giving away a signed copy
of a feast for crows signed by George R
Martin all you have to do to enter is be
a subscriber and leave a comment on this
video so here we go Stannis is sacrifice
starts to turn sour this is at the
beginning of his worst day ever
seriously when Melisandre started to
hear about all the bad things that were
happening it was just one thing right
after the other half of the cell swords
have left they took their horses with
them what's that you have some more bad
news well it couldn't be any worse than
half my men leaving oh wait no my wife
just hung herself a lot of this gets
into Melisandre misinterpreting her
visions which she's known to do we have
to jump to the Arya storyline real quick
because I think there's this really
important line that's relevant to what's
going on with Melisandre jaqen says that
only death can pay for life what does
that mean in the context of Stannis and
Melisandre maybe the gift that the red
God is giving is something that they
just haven't seen yet it's not like
ordering something off of Amazon I mean
it's not like you sacrifice your
daughter and you get the printer you
want in the mail like when Jack and says
a debt is owed that works two ways
so that also ties in with potential Jon
Snow storylines so even though it looks
like Melisandre is getting ready to cry
she still might get some great gift from
the red God if there's anything you can
say about Stannis is that he is
committed like he sees the Bolton's
riding on them he still pulls his sword
onto number nine Samwell wants to go to
Old Town
this is a storyline that's right out of
the books and we really are like you
know right where the story in the books
ends Samwell goes to Old Town to learn
to become a maester with Gilly and the
baby the only changes is that maester
aemon went with them and died on the
journey so just a minor change there he
died at the wall instead of dying on the
way there they're actually already
scouting locations for Game of Thrones
season
and it looks like one of the locations
that they've found is something that
could be old town Samwell speech just
confirms that the only thing I took
issue with was when Samwell said
watching Gilly and the baby die would be
worse than a thousand white walkers and
I was like whoa hold up
you did not see Episode eight white
walkers are way worse than anything
except maybe getting stabbed by arya a
thousand times onto number eight
brilliant finally kills Stannis he's
such a big character that they had to
let him go out like a warrior so that's
that's why they let him kill those two
Bolton soldiers but there was no way he
was going to survive that's why they
showed all that blood flowing out from
him whenever the camera panned up though
and revealed that it was Brienne I felt
like it could have been anybody I didn't
know if they would actually let her kill
him in the finale you can't say that the
show doesn't pay big plot points off it
is a big change in the books Britt you
and Brienne is in a completely different
place when this is going on in the
battle for Winterfell is like a winds of
winter thing so we don't know how it's
gonna play out in the book it might go
the same way it was such a satisfying
moment I totally do not have any issues
with any of the changes they made on to
number seven though Aria shows mercy to
Meryn Trant now confirmed pedophile who
else feels like him whipping all those
little girls was just like a little much
and then he gut punched the girl that
Aria was pretending to be really
anything he would have done with any of
those girls would have been super creepy
because they are like really little
girls but this is going into like
torture porn area can you imagine what
he's done that he hasn't been caught for
like what does he do when he's back in
King's Landing they just wanted to make
that Arya payoff seen that much sweeter
but I feel like it was so extreme that
it became abstract but even given all
the ice zombies that we've seen you know
air quotes I feel like this is the
closest game of Thrones we'll get to a
slasher flick the craziest whip pan in
that moment though is watching Arya go
from this you know stabby little girl
like slicing his throat saying who are
you
you are no one then on a dime turning
into this scared little girl like oh my
god I can't see on to number six
Arya loses her sight also really big
book moment in the books Arya kill
someone it's I mean it's a different
person but she still kills someone she's
not supposed to then she wakes up the
next morning and she can't see the extra
part that they added on was the magic
with the faces so the faceless men do
practice a certain amount of sorcery
when they're changing phases there's
like a magical component to it so if
you're confused as to you know like why
she kept pulling all those faces off
till she saw her own she wasn't
hallucinating she's and get poisoned or
anything like that that was happening in
real life like right in front of her
eyes it's part of the faceless men's
magic that she hasn't learned yet one of
the hardest things to judge is like that
is the timeline like how long between
episode 1 in episode 10 has it been
really I think it's been a couple months
so she gets stuck in the black cells for
a while so I think that's a better
benchmark on to number 5 though Sansa
and reek escape minor disappointment
with this storyline Sansa does show some
courage like she's ready to walk into
the face of death but reek is the person
who gets the kill I understand he's on a
Redemption arc so it was pretty likely
that he was going to save Sansa in some
way but it would have been nice to see
Sansa stab Miranda like say with the
barrel opener that she used to pick the
lock usually people complain when a
character gets killed off but I think in
the case of Sansa people will be more
upset that she didn't kill a bunch of
characters off it's just one of those
storylines that's vastly changed from
the books because they actually they run
into Stannis's army in the books before
Stannis marches on Winterfell so now
we're like we're completely new
territory that being said now that
they're on the run I feel like it's a
good opportunity for Sanchez to step up
because we can barely function as a
human being he can barely speak in full
sentences on to number four glorious and
poisons Marcella this is one of the
better rug pulling moments in the
episode because they have this really
nice moment she finally says I know I
totally know about you and Mom I'm so
happy that you're my dad and then BAM
she looks like she's dead I can't say
that I'm super close to the Marcella
character but I'm really interested in
the twist that this is going to open up
in the sand snake plot because think
about it
Trish Danes on the boat he loved
Marcella he's gonna be pissed he's gonna
tell his father Prince Doran who's gonna
be pissed at the sand snakes
ilaria did swear fealty to Prince Doran
I mean she was choose weeping openly at
his feet you could argue that he told
her to poison Myrcella but he was so
open about not killing little girls so I
don't think that's the case I think she
went rogue you also to remember that
final moment with Bronn and tyene sand
where she's like maybe you'll see me
sooner rather than later that's probably
going to be the sand snakes in season
six
that's another one of those storylines
they've changed a whole bunch so we
could see Sansa Nate showing up in
places that they show up in the books or
they could completely change it they
definitely made hanging plot lines like
you know slam to blacks a big thing in
this episode where it's like they give
you like the oh my god reaction and then
it's just gone
like you have to wait till season six to
find out what's gonna happen on to
number three Daenerys gets captured by
the khalasar I totally love Daenerys and
drogon like he's very clearly licking
his wounds and super tired but he's just
like he's like a little puppy who just
shakes Daenerys off like he's like I'm
tired go away mom they want you to feel
like he's incapacitated so Daenerys is
on her own he's not going to save her
from the khalasar they did a good job of
like feeding us information though you
know she drops that engagement ring I
think it's his daughter's engagement
ring so that Daario and Jorah will be
able to find it and they can track her
down if you're confused about why that
circle of horses started growing on
growing around her that's just a battle
technique to keep her from escaping the
khalasar itself is actually made up of a
bunch of people that used to belong to
Khal Drogo's khalasar when he died a
bunch of other cows rushed in to fill
the vacuum
so the Khal that found Daenerys is just
like the next biggest one after Khal
Drogo I know people get really worried
about Daenerys but she has this thing
whereby she finds herself in shitty
situations and completely turns them
around so do not expect the worst we all
set to give a big shout out to Varys who
is now with Tyrion try not to burn down
marine while we're away seriously now
you have two bros and marine beerus and
tyrion and then you have two bros on a
road trip Jorah and Daario that's
probably going to be one of the funniest
things next season Jorah and Daario
fares had this really awesome line to
where he said it's a grand old city
choking on violence and deceit if only
you had some experience with something
like that
he was obviously talking about King's
Landing also a grand old city choking on
violence and deceit if anything about
Paris though is that he just he comes
out of nowhere he's like The Terminator
like the t1000 he just slowly comes out
of the wall like you didn't even see him
they're on to number two though Circe's
walk of shame also right out of the
books they do a really good job of
showing you just how far she has to walk
from bailer Sept to the red keep is a
long freakin way there's no way you guys
would have been able to tell this but if
you were falling like the behind the
scenes production
was as big controversy about the city
where they filmed that not allowing them
to do a naked walk through the streets
with the production ended up doing is
using a naked body double for Cersei
because she has like a no nudity clause
in her contract and then shooting the
rest of her whenever she was like
shoulders up so they didn't have to use
a lot of CG to combine her head with the
other body it's just like if you got
excited about watching Cersei naked
you're not actually looking at Cersei
naked that's another actress with Lena
Headey 's head on her body it is totally
okay we will not judge you here for
getting excited about Cersei walking
naked through the streets I really
started to absorb her emotions as she
was walking through the streets like she
slowly starts to break down people
shouting at her like the nun ringing
that Bell once I started spitting on her
throwing trash I had to look away for
you know for just a second because it
was pretty terrible but even as much as
it seems like she's completely lost it
like she's just completely broken down
she's bloody she's covered in filth
the minute she hits the main gate of the
red key is when she just completely
breaks as a human being I was a little
upset when they took it right back by
introducing Robert strong like right
away so you have her at her lowest point
she almost has this religious experience
an actual legitimate religious
experience as she walks through the
doors and then they take it all back
it's like she's completely 180 back -
terrible person when she sees this big
strong person to kill all of her enemies
you know they do not know anything about
Robert strong about pycelle science
experiment which is definitely the
mountain with necrotic tissue you can
actually see it between his eye holes
don't forget though sir she still has
her trial with the faith so that's
clearly going to be a season six thing
and finally no surprise here by number
one WTF moment for the watch Jon Snow
gets stabbed and left for dead
all the show people know exactly how the
book readers have felt since 2011
seriously this moment has been around
for the last four years with fans trying
to figure out how Jon Snow might be able
to survive it and you would be correct
if you assume there are a couple tinfoil
theories the most legit being that
Melisandre is going to resurrect him
which i think is going to be the case
the other possibility being that he
works into ghosts or somehow he gets
turned into a white Walker really it
takes you back to when Ned Stark was
killed that the main hero or who you
thought the main hero was was getting
killed off everybody just remember
though Samwell said
very clearly to Ollie don't worry John
always comes back that's a very
important line John always comes back
the really similar cliffhanger to this
like that you know is he dead is he not
dead cliffhanger was back from Episode
four where we didn't know about
Barristan Selmy and grey worm and we
didn't find out who was alive and who
was dead till the next episode the
problem with this moment though is that
it is like very much a book 5
cliffhanger so the books won't tell us
whether or not John's alive till winds
of winter which is at least a year away
I feel like people would have been
screaming no matter what Dan and Dave
did but I feel like not letting us know
what happened to John is the smart
decision here's my big question for you
guys do you feel like Dan and Dave did
the right thing in not telling us what's
going to happen to Jon Snow and how do
you think that he's going to come back
I'm also thinking about all the people
that were so bummed the Benjen didn't
show up in the episode seriously that
early recap of Benjen posted and people
had so many theories I tried to stay
away from it because I saw it so late
and there was the IMDB post saying the
Benjen was going to be in the episode
generally I've just learned not to trust
IMDB and I feel like they didn't need to
put benjin in the recap I think the
reason they did is because it'd been so
long since the name benjin had been said
out loud on the show those of you that
are still really upset about Shireen
especially since it seemed to amount to
nothing just remember that death has to
pay for life so I think that life is
going to manifest in the form of Jon
Snow coming back now that we've had the
finale what's going to happen is is
tomorrow I'm going to post my season six
predictions I'm going to do an extra
giveaway I'm doing the book giveaway in
this video but tomorrow there'll be an
extra giveaway in my predictions video
and I'll announce the winners of both of
those in the QA video they should also
post Monday night or at least by Tuesday
morning and by the time those drop I
should have an idea of what my next
bonus video is going to be but I will do
a bonus video later this week I'm not
going to wait a full week to do another
bonus video if you have any requests
just leave them in the comments for
those either really want me to do like a
rating for this finale relative to the
other finales you know what I'll say is
I'll say thumbs down for Sansa thumbs up
for long payoffs and some of the really
good cliffhangers in another thumbs down
for that final Cersei moment exciting to
see Robert strong but really upsetting
to see that her character didn't learn
anything from that experience other than
she should kill more
even faster if you want to give the
episode a thumbs up for anything though
I would give it a thumbs up for thematic
consistency so we open with Stannis's
very bad to worst day that's kind of a
metaphor for the entire episode and
what's going to happen in episode 1 of
season 6 like you think things can't get
any worse and then all of a sudden they
do we have not hit rock bottom yet so
you guys haven't seen it earlier today I
posted a video all about Aegon the
conquerer in the early history of the
Targaryen family you can click here to
watch that and you can click here for my
episode 9 video thank you so much
watching everybody let's high five I'll
see you guys tomorrow